>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER.
THANKS FOR THAT.
WELL, SOME YEARS AGO CNN
HIRED FORMER OBAMA OFFICIAL
JIM SCIUTTO AND HE HAS BEEN
DELIVERING FOR THEM EVER
SINCE.
ON MONDAY SCIUTTO APPEARED
WITH WHAT SOUNDED LIKE A
BLOCKBUSTER STORY.
HERE'S WHAT IT WAS.
THE CIA HAD BEEN FORCED TO
SPIRIT AN AGENT OUT OF
RUSSIA BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
BUNGLED HANDLING OF
INTELLIGENCE AND PUT THAT
AGENT'S LIFE IN DANGER.
>> MULTIPLE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
WITH DIRECT KNOWLEDGE TELL
ME IN A PREVIOUSLY
UNDISCLOSED SECRET MISSION
IN 2017 THE U.S.S.
SUCCESSFULLY EXTRACTED FROM
RICKENBACKER ONE OF ITS
HIGHEST LEVEL COVERT SOURCES
INSIDE THE RUSSIA
GOVERNMENT, A PERSON
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THE
DISCUSSIONS SAID THAT THE
REMOVAL OF THE RUSSIAN WAS
DRIVEN, IN PART, BY CONCERNS
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION REPEATEDLY
MISHANDLED CLASSIFIED
INTELLIGENCE WHICH COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO EXPOSING THE
COVERT SOURCE AS A SPY.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER BOMBSHELL
FROM JIM SCIUTTO AND THE
GENIUSES AT CNN JUST LIKE
THE LAST 10 BOMBSHELLS THAT
WERE GOING TO BRING DOWN THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS ONE TURNED OUT TO BE A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED THAN
IT SEEMS.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE HAS DETAILS ON
THAT.
HEY, CATHERINE.
>> WELL, TUCKER, BASED ON
TWO DECADES COVERING THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
THERE IS NO HARDER DECISION
FOR THE CIA THAN PULLING AN
INTELLIGENCE ASSET.
IT'S A LONG AND DELIBERATE
PROCESS.
AND THE FINAL CALL IS BASED
ON MULTIPLE FACTORS, NOT A
SINGLE EVENT OR INDIVIDUAL.
RESPONDING TO THE CNN REPORT
BLAMING THE PRESIDENT, THE
CIA TOOK THE UNUSUAL STEP OF
ISSUING THIS STATEMENT:
MISGUIDED SPECULATION THAT
THE PRESIDENT'S HANDLING OF
OUR NATION'S MOST SENSITIVE
INTELLIGENCE, WHICH HE HAS
ACCESS TO EACH AND EVERY
DAY, DROVE AN ALLEGED
EXFILTRATION OPERATION IS
INACCURATE CITING ANONYMOUS
SOURCES REPORTED THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S MAY 17TH
DISCLOSURE OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO THE RUSSIANS
ABOUT TERRORISM WAS A
PIVOTAL MOMENT.
RENEWING DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
ABOUT THE ACCESS RISK OF
EXPOSURE.
THE OVAL OFFICE MEETING WAS
DESCRIBED TO FOX NEWS AS,
QUOTE, IRRELEVANT TO THE
CIA'S DECISION-MAKING.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT ABOUT RUSSIA'S
ELECTION INTERFERENCE
PUBLICLY RELEASED IN 2017 AS
WELL AS MEDIA ATTENTION
ABOUT THE SOURCE AND THEIR
PROXIMITY TO PRESIDENT PUTIN
WERE A MAJOR FACTOR FOR THE
AGENCY.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE CIA DOES NOT PULL
AN ASSET BASED ON A SINGLE
FACTOR.
ONCE THE ASSET IS PULLED,
THEY CAN'T GO BACK INTO PLAY
AND SIGNIFICANTLY THE ASSETS
REMAINING NETWORK OF
CONTACTS, IN THIS CASE
RUSSIA, COULD BE RETALIATED